no GSI and what welcome to punch-drunk
sports
where's winners win blue tube and Betty
sighs ah we're winners win we win here
you want to win you come join us guys
welcome to our most multicultural
diverse podcast glad that's right I mean
we got guys and a black guy
please love the show [ __ ] podcast
favorite good friend all LA Laker
protester cream asses everybody cream
how are you I'm excellent this is gonna
be an epic episode yeah yeah I've got a
lot of [ __ ] to get into man does it make
you upset that there's this notion that
black people are always late yet the
white person on the show is not here
right now I'm not upset at that at all
I'm always on time you I'm the black
dude that breaks down the stereotype I
like that about everybody on this show
is generally late I'm here on weed know
I can this is the earliest we've started
this show and probably the last two
years and it is still 11 12 is that is
that Chad's dad right there daddy died a
follow all creams IG it's cream dot
period Matthews yeah I did actually me
and Clipper Darryl go down right there
the man dude whipper Daryl showed up to
the Laker process that was [ __ ]
ridiculous that's so great
that's great you know things are bad
with the Clippers are Pro telling us now
what were the Lakers protesting the
[ __ ] that's going on man just there
you guys suck you guys finally sucking
all protesting the fact you know lo you
sucked before and never had the protest
we're protesting the fact that is chaos
man it's chaos like well no direction
like you can't tell me there's a plan
like I was on like no notes
drop rate hoggle
Podcast never a candidate to dude you
guys just [ __ ] panicked you know I
mean but look at who everybody's hiring
there's nothin all the good coaches are
gone what we're seeing right now is the
results of to franchise going to the
finals for the last five years and
LeBron James been in the last ten years
that there hasn't been a lot of finals
coaches so there's not a lot guys to
pick from so that you know this is a
result of LeBron James dominance in the
East and the and the and the Washington
I mean excuse me the Golden State
Warriors dominance in the West now let
me just say this what the Lakers are
going through is is social justice
warrior political correctness [ __ ]
playing out in real time which is women
can fix everything and young people can
do the job you don't need old people to
do it right which is total Hollywood
which is get rid of the old guard put in
shiny new objects because anybody we put
in is gonna succeed which is genie boss
can fix the Lakers cuz her brother was a
[ __ ] and women know better and that
[ __ ] Luke Walton even though he had
18 games with the greatest team ever
assembled
he could do a [ __ ] coaching job yeah
I mean thank you it's been punch-drunk
sports we'll see you guys next week I
love winning I love winning I love
winning
nah it's it's [ __ ] going alright
yeah it's like no direction and I mean
I'm gonna ride it out you don't saying
I'm a Laker fan for life I don't give a
[ __ ] I love that the five years that's
been bad as you're riding it out I've
been a clipper fan and a Knick fan hey
that's your choice right you act like
you're like you're such a this is
starving for what you just said right
there is the equivalent of chicks doing
no make up selfies right there acting
like you're [ __ ] great this is a
tough time we usually win 1 out of every
3 champ is the natural [ __ ] cycle of
pro sports and no but seriously though
it wouldn't even
bad not what it wouldn't even be bad it
would still be bad but it would be more
bearable if we had a plan if you could
see what we're trying to do you you
don't get a plan you don't get that
listen dude the the best example of
sports wait we don't get a plan no
because you guys think you have to win
everywhere and that's not the net the
nature of the business because you guys
are so bloodthirsty you sent DeAngelo
Russell out and he [ __ ] is it all
start now no and see that's the thing
someone has to be someone has to be held
responsible for that like whose decision
was that was that magic was that palinka
because that person needs to go you know
send not only the Angela learn that
magic is a great businessman is
laughable he literally gets white
billionaires take Magic Johnson and make
him the face of businesses and he just
says see they're gone
I beat aids and that's all he has to say
and everyone's like all right no as far
as making decisions like he basketball
decisions his record isn't what that is
not good what is that picture that Chris
put up L and L by the [ __ ] what is this
the Rays stadium is hilarious and true a
Raiders fan dude nah you've made
terrible choices with your teams I'm not
gonna lie but that's Stephanie my next
statement
I appreciate you stick by them though
you don't say cuz I'm a Rams fan or to
them going to st. Louis yeah yeah yeah
so when it turns back around you don't
get to love that yeah you don't get you
got on people yeah and that's how I feel
about these five years for us I'm like
Laker fans Laker haters this is why we
pull our dick out on y'all when we win
because this is you see the kind of [ __ ]
we're getting now I get clipper Daryl is
showing up at our [ __ ] process you
wait till we win our next one you know
I'm gonna be at the parade naked on a
float
Ronnie's doing everybody up on a float
me doing them by Jason how are you good
guys good good good good good
Scotty just walked in jessup any dates
yeah I got 13 dates I like to plug okay
in 500 years I'll be dead as [ __ ]
I'll be at paper scissors on the rocks
in Dover used the promo code not a real
show for a hundred free tickets albeit
glory glory hallelujah in San
Francisco's super suckfest
on Christmas morning that can't go wrong
chicks are so hot on the other side yeah
I don't think the chicks but I'm down
for it and I am on the new Jeremiah
Watkins podcast that just dropped
yesterday and if you like my impressions
every single person that you know Triple
E calls in Don Barris calls in Ari
Shaffir calls in Theo von calls in every
single impression I do calls in on that
show it's pretty funny the king of the
impressions of nobody knows who they are
yes he is the best at my buddy Rick from
high school calls him my old high school
gym teacher mr. does the [ __ ] you
wrestle call him he calls in yeah Brian
Barnett calls in thank you so yeah it's
actually really funny it's a very funny
podcast Jeremiah wonders so if you want
to listen to that give it a go cream do
you got any dates coming out you'd like
to talk to us about just follow me on
social media my Instagram and probably
Instagram follows you got not enough
don't look him up let's find out what
everybody's got an idea I don't have a
lot I have less than 5,000 I'll probably
add it too for sure that upsets me so do
I forget outside I don't even have 3,500
upsets me let's get it to 5,000 guys if
you're a punch-drunk fan and you have a
culture Oh some pork even if even if not
bloated Tebow 5017
5017 let's get me the Tebow get the
Tebow is adjacent t-ball 5017 there's
him in Jeremiah yeah
yeah look at your much of fun podcast
have you done it yeah but I enjoyed your
Martha I loved Jeremiah that thing he
has is cool where you can judge it
changes all your voices sounds like a
phone call Jeremiah works hard and it's
a young Christian warrior this came in
coffee's good it was just a do I was
gonna mention now hey this [ __ ] you told
me to get hey the night job if you love
Kate man coffee you want a little break
on that [ __ ] go to caveman coffee calm
use the promo code but hugs drunk and
you will get a discount on that coffee
yeah I think it's 15% off you get 15%
off for coffee so how delicious is that
I was gonna say I've only taken a couple
sips yeah I can already tell ya these
are great dude they're great I've done
like hardcore drugs and drinking coffee
gives me the same kind of jack feeling
that you when I'm on a drink amen coffee
it'll make a cheat on your girlfriend
should we let her in oh Sh you just ever
sit there like a [ __ ] late loser
there she there she has to fight nany is
in the building
fight Manny likes to make entrances like
Ric Flair whoo the fight nany is in the
building we got here later than black
people how are you
fine you the baby what's the baby doing
she's very actually talks a lot
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba ba-ba-ba where's my real
daddy Bonaparte words was pretty she's a
gene that's great we you have a
narcissistic baby that's right no she
says it about flowers but she could say
flowers oh billable words all right yeah
she's like monkeys whenever she loves
animals
oh well animals love your babe I don't
even think it's really your baby because
she's too smart I know it's great
I think Jeff had a baby with somebody
else and you just thought you gave birth
arrogant I carried it somehow that
happens out there how do we know it's
Jeff's baby here hey uh fine Annie you
got any um you got any uh dates you want
to push anything nothing nope no show
sore nothing guys ah ABX org that's a B
x.org
absolute extract is proud to present
comedy chaos la May 21st in the main
room at 10:30 p.m. we got a killer
lineup of [ __ ] murderers okay
can you go to my Instagram since we've
shown everybody else's [ __ ] Instagram
why can we get Sam's Instagram where can
we go out back up to the top okay here
we go
look at that line on fire we got Tony
Baker Bert Kreischer Ian bagg my man
branch Brandon [ __ ] Bryan Callen Tony
Hinchcliffe myself the master of
ceremonies that is all there and is
brought to you by our good friends at
absolute extract they got all the [ __ ]
you need you need flour you need vape
pens you need to [ __ ] some [ __ ] for
that vagina of yours huh you want to get
your [ __ ] high what about that
I need all that bass is like yeah
that's like I'm doing chewing tobacco
right now and the other one look at the
contrast you got that one on the left
and in that other one well in guyshave
dude those are the two faces that is
what are you talking about cool and then
mama mama murder murder face that's my
serial killer face that's my calm cool
collected that's getting interviewed by
the cops because they think I might be
the serial killer and that's me playing
that's his palm face after six lines of
coke and that's his nose doing stand-up
yeah yeah let's hear my followers I got
let's go down see how me fine yeah
that's what I wanted to go to back up to
the top that's nothing compared the half
my friends dude my friends are all like
[ __ ] triple six digits it's all
relative though yeah if I was a hot
chick like hot chicks they're boulders
are like pesos it takes a thousand equal
one real water I always say that if I
had a vagina I would be five million
Instagram you were talking about last
night find that chick or ass look at
this [ __ ] in her pesos 27 22 million
people right on tree of America but
closest one of their poor but hey click
one of her poles
she gets like a hundred views no dude
dude look at that dude she few she gets
oh wow okay yeah she's to it without
this yeah that looks too skinny very
like I wouldn't knock bottom out of that
camel toe look at this like hey to
everybody like this picture where I'm
holding up this [ __ ] oh I'm holding
it up that's been punch mark everybody
all the time hot chick funny it's like
look at me I'm trying to be serious
hahahahaha what's he saying dude look at
that
I like the captions though like you
always like nothing to do they don't
like it it's like no it's not supposed
to be a nude photo
hey power rake hotness can we all agree
we'd you like number three is integrand
models like anyone can be an instagram
on some are super hot some are not so
hot then playmates right playmates are
there and then on top of that is
Victoria Secret models secret are the
NBA players of hot right I like straight
thing you pay millions for it then above
that to me waitresses at Denny's to you
entire would usually have you heard
Tiger Woods is getting sued right now
because one click that one spying
look at me I'm buying candy and my
underwear am I crazy almost two million
rights my crazy nerdy and I'm reading a
book [ __ ] you can't read yeah I am so
she has somebody whose job it is it's
just a block and take pictures of her
she does what is her nationality [ __ ]
creeper over there who claims she's
actress - yeah she's in Fast and Furious
get out of my country right what I'm not
up on my supermodels man I'm on those
ratchet hoes on yes - yeah when you got
shot with not that face well there's big
strip somewhere that is almost that hot
they are that wrong that's what they
just didn't like she's got somebody
famous and raging that parlay right
there like ghetto trash and they're just
like I can't believe I'm blowing eight
guys in this dog fart porn out okay it's
just
for 300 likes alright Jason what would
you like to talk about today I'd like to
hear what you think I'm gonna talk about
this ratchet ho we're talking about up
here okay her [ __ ] you were so
uninterested anything I just hate these
she added King James I wonder if LeBron
replied to that yeah he got two million
likes on there like the poor King James
I just want to be friends just checking
in on both oh my boo King James
yeah wondering if he responded today I
wonder if his wife respond better did I
bet you did she's like kiss dicks she
pretty
aye she's probably like I wish a
[ __ ] would cheat I wish him on
the phone I'm gonna half this [ __ ] go
get some new dick go bang some Devin
Booker ding or some [ __ ] hilarious
ohh acting crazy
look at that we're on a boat drinking
champagne doing our best life ever
yeah I hope that I hope that ship sinks
like Tim Conley dies and his chick gets
to walk around for free yeah because she
believes nutsacks that's your job
hi do you want your nutsack relief if
you're a billionaire and you want to hit
that not that now we're talking if
you're a billionaire relieve nutsack and
you wanna you want to hit this perfectly
symmetrical face the billionaire's is
hitting the phony dollar strip malls in
Florida what do you talk that's all it's
gotta be weird let's say she marries
like some really rich powerful guy and
then she finds out he marrying a plumber
she cheated on him on her with just some
[ __ ] balls wait that's what's got
Drive women nuts it's like like you know
what it is usually hangs out with the
fat Jew it's like is anybody do any do
anybody make worse entertainment
decisions and hot chicks like big
business me fat Jew
oh and has money the guy caught stealing
from everybody look at that see if he
can get it in that video that one right
there
someone do fart sounds yeah I think that
was her look how funny she it's like
look at me I waved my hand my butt
shakes am I crazy
I know she's kidding
she spent an entire day thinking about
that she literally gets more views than
The Tonight Show of Instagram [ __ ] you
Fallon [ __ ] you [ __ ] your show
this [ __ ] is the new king of late-night
talk show so Johnny told me you big oaf
right after all this you followed her
monkey but why your daughter's I
beautiful speaking I'd like to go hiking
oh speaking of monkey I'd like to go
hiking with her two of us go hiking one
of us comes back and then I got a TV
credit on Dateline for a song or [ __ ]
head off in the woods I bet you eat her
ass oh yeah let me do that first before
you kill her I see so many pornos I know
what her butthole looks like why she
look like that right probably looks like
that rapper I got fly like take a get
higher baby gotta getta getta get the
feeling the other day those are the
words are so dangerous homology her soon
as I get off of here I'm gonna DM her
high let's see if she ever gets back to
me I'm so [ __ ] talented you're like
what do you think I'm an optic on that
all of them whoo humming NBA players
oh yeah no yeah they slide in the dance
all day hey the and I know we did did we
do negative chick I mean we didn't net
who are the worst athletes but who the
top athletes the bang as a chick power
rank them Oh could you only like UFC
it's like I don't even know what that
means not a football player they're too
big okay okay so they're not in the top
three hi lovely NBA they would be which
is shocking baseball they shake you know
looking more money hard everybody I know
they're saying like athletic cool dudes
though you know me I'm Erica yeah but
worldwide soccer yeah Thank You old or
whatever it has more Twitter followers
than or Instagram followers than anybody
yeah no he has like 70 million no and
they're like in shape too yeah how about
him getting charged with rape everyone's
like what yeah I'm sorry 160 half of
America 166 million followers he has
right we're talking about a hot chick
that has 20 million
yeah 170 million for this guy yeah now
he gets his share yeah and she's a knee
right everyone's like what yeah come on
the guy who everybody every wife would
leave their man in a heartbeat to be
with welcome in front of their mayor
honey I gotta give her no no I mean you
thought American athletes made a lot of
money
those guys are at [ __ ] stupid gym and
LeBron bolts got lifetime contracts from
Nike I know that be a billion dollars ya
know Ronaldo every time the World Cup
comes around like dude I know he gets he
got worldwide he could [ __ ] anybody on
the planet in the world is no more
imagine that you could [ __ ] anybody on
the planet I have imagined that
I can't even imagine I can't wrap my
brain around them I can't
ya know first gets his share right no no
I get it
but he has the money like he's in in
shape I got friends owned by a hooker
the other day I got paid you $150 why
are you talking about your ex-boyfriend
the whole time you didn't a nosebleed
that a Dodger game yo I'm in love why is
she sitting so far away
she's in the know guys this is the guys
thing it's like did take me you can best
get guys boners yes okay take a picture
of me I want to give guys boners what a
six-pack dude do not stop personally uh
to bank please talk about sports I hope
you this is good I we go to every single
photo dude I'm bout to listen to me dude
the number one female sport on the
planet is pornography make no no no I
know they should put out rook my heart
Jeff writes rookie card before she took
a thousand black dicks okay her key card
nicely you want to talk about dicks I'm
talking about blue to go to blue to calm
for the first ever to bowl that brings
you performance to another level if you
like sex you'll love blue tube combo
salute you offers men a
performance-enhancing for the bedroom
would you like the last longer go extra
rounds I can prove it works right now
I'm rock-hard Sam blue to makes
chewables for an act with the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
two Bulls can work up to twice as fat I
mean you chew it boom your rock-hard
boners you know what else I love about
this made in America how much you love
American boners over the rest of the
boners be honest man do you love
American boners [ __ ] a fight Danny loves
them just say you love American boners
but you know I liked before I was a
mother like you can you get some money
from these people do you like American
boners of course I do I most an American
okay here we go guys that was that I
hate for all foreign boners yeah [ __ ]
for boners
I want my boner pills made America
filled the raw wood glue chew okay
pillow yeah blue tube wall okay I want
big rock our boners making a wall that
guess what White Walkers couldn't get
through that boner wall because it's
made by American boners all right
American [ __ ] boners all right
blue two bulls are prescribed online by
doctor or made in the USA USA USA
nobody's with me on that one you and
your partner will love it
okay visit blue to calm and get the
first shipment for free when you use a
promo code tinfoil after that just fine
I mean excuse me punch it's wrong punch
drunk
thanks blue to keep your brain calm use
the promo code punch drunk dude I rock
boners all [ __ ] day dog she will be
like a [ __ ] man hey after that
goddamn Instagram page I'm with you on
that I'm sitting at a table with three
bonus yeah judge in my defense I was
hard when I walked in the other day long
I had a rock-hard boner i shanked the
[ __ ] person with it I ran off Thank
You blue - for stopping me from getting
[ __ ] mugged on you love boners right
okay what do you guys want to talk Jason
what do you want to talk about I want it
I want to keep looking at every one of
these chicks photos for the for the next
two and a half hours okay nany did you
see that
sarunas fighting again in less than a
month yeah this guy's nuts
yeah or broke I mean like a bee robots
did you hear his last fight he goes I'm
fighting cuz I want to get a pool for my
baby it's like you better to pull at
this point in your you know he's back
and literally every time a courier
accepts
and never had a belt heald's every
single record most knockouts most tap
outs most wins longest win streaks every
single record but never got a belt Daisy
a hall-of-famer chase absolutely you
don't think so yeah I definitely do
I just ask you I just thought yeah I
just like when's he gonna I'm sorry for
speaking when's he gonna when does it
end for him when he can't with the pool
yeah I mean is old not young can we just
he's already had 50 fights how many
fights yet just think about how long PJ
Ben's been fighting oh my god think
about how long that guys not fighting BJ
yeah are you in okay man [ __ ] PJ Ben
Franklin are you impressed by a seven
fight blue streak Oh PJ ban hasn't won
in my 2010 that's almost 10 years not
now but ahead of her but if you had a 10
year that's like a thing that never
can't win now you can't break this tree
perfect Susan Lucci up [ __ ] in the UFC
what do you retired like six years ago
is when he should have left and it was
like my borough I remember I think I
watched with you guys it was like it
might be a season Lucci Cerrone might be
the Susan Lucci see all that but he's
got all those wins without a belt BJ
Penn or PJ Ben might be the let me tell
you don't they give him I'm not gonna
talk why did he fight yeah well they
haven't given him to her own he's gotten
two title fights no no no no yeah yeah
I'm talking about BG I didn't say
goodbye he wants to fight for a title
Tyco didn't want to fight in the tank I
had that after this fight yes he said
that after the last right that's you
haven't won in ten years what in the
world makes you think you should get a
title fight that's either care
he's a character it's good to go to
Bellator or [ __ ] some key fighting
and don't win and what about that
knockout rose I thought I mean you do
that slow motion heard very dangerous
Jeffrey and he's like she could have
died you need to see that lovely trying
to sports podcast and you're sleeping
during a sporting event no it was like
2:00 in the morning if he like had a
spot that night he came home and woke me
up and I had already like read all the
highlights and all that and I was
texting him yeah he was at the store so
I was texting him like seven-five and
then like I saw this but he came in like
she was he hadn't seen it yet so we
think you need to see this she was doing
great against hers
yeah that's I think guaranteed rule for
sure now she's like I don't know what I
want to fight anymore so what people
lose off like that though minun in the
first round that will make the second
round
cuz she's probably like a man another
inch and that could have been mine yeah
that was her ass alrighty we saw her
look at that I'd like to I'd like to see
a rematch now I wait a bill she could
have broke her neck you know for real
all that you can't spike him on their
head real easy right I mean that's done
we were talking about this the other
night on on a patreon a by the way go to
punch lines patron feel free to
subscribe
dude we had a great one we talked about
pedophilia for now we were talking about
that please yeah but I brought a couple
hot kids with the I this nitro is
kicking in yo told you it's great what
do you I'm the driver
but somebody last night was saying that
they uh like I don't think they should
have a rematch there's somebody who else
they gonna fight it's not like there's a
shitload of people in that division it's
not a bunch of stick people out there
hey can we can we talk
NBA playoffs Oh
even though my team is not in it this is
being one of the better so are we done
with it all so let's just go over who's
fighting right now your boy Diaz is fun
yeah I wanted to bring that up too it's
Anaheim
it should be a field trip I'm here I
will go the second one is this you'll
let us know
August 17 the next thing is is that your
boy Georges st. Pierre wants the [ __ ]
fight um his dream at she called it
could be oh yeah no good fight watch
that I go home of yours watch that I
might I'm like that's similar similar
fighting styles to don't do it have
similar fighting styles to I think it
would be great cuz they're both great
run this is a good fight no one can beat
khabib you know dude nobody can beat
[ __ ] George st. Pierre you don't know
George st. Pierre dawg do you mean
everyone no no [ __ ] three-year-old
supposed to be training with the bear
man I'm not putting him up fighter in
with it alright Jessica I is fighting
for a thing and she gets voted hottest
body in the UFC okay really
okay oh you got the best body let me see
your body weight Cerrone is fighting for
that belt then with Tony Ferguson Tony
Ferguson yeah no good
I think yeah well those aren't good
picture now but he has real tits because
I like I didn't karate hotties got the
prize because you like [ __ ] is you got
any nice ass lady boys look at that guy
on the Left wearing a bra she has the
best body I've done my research
I remember watching that in the Karate
hotties not good let's look up this guy
that Samsung about karate hottie I
didn't like karate hotties nude spread
on Sports Illustrated though I thought
she was
to a muscular we turn my hair but look
at that nude one I didn't like those
well it's covered right there but it was
a magazine cover and I thought she was
too muscular mmm okay we're having
issues with Talan no that's who I said
it's got a hot body okay yeah no I agree
she's very pretty she's hotter than just
guys don't even body pretty either yeah
that's cool
that's a yes the answer is yes
[Laughter]
patrons hands totally I think this yeah
if I hear this again Shipman
she's a chipmunk she's just a chipmunk
and she's young go to the hottest female
MMA fighters over he talks to them
dude we should have a podcast where we
all beat off know what I was in studio
and I gave him some lotion he couldn't
get a boner
no that's fine I don't have a problem
with that but not together okay fun and
get that word luck in MMA this is how we
talk about yes you know go to the hot
ones look up hottest UFC dudes look up
how did you ever see dudes I want to see
what the girls are talking about that is
[ __ ] for our two women listeners here
we go let's see what the see who's got
the but best [ __ ] hottest dick
is that what you're looking uh I don't
know look up look up cutest UFC male
[ __ ] look at the hottest champion now
that I didn't do what are you ned words
on that [ __ ] list go down go up go up
go up go up
why is he an Edwards I'm it's a [ __ ]
under rules we took a wrong turn
early I need some goddamn dick Johnny
I'm gonna eat five blue cheese drink
Achaemenid coffee nitro and bet on D si
that one of these guys is gonna load me
up like a shotgun go to my I made you
watch yesterday I would never let them
hear it we can't hear okay it makes me
laugh so hard I've been this got
sentient laughing you film out trolling
for anonymous trysts in new york's
leather bar underworld the most talked
about film of 1980 comes home with the
new cruising electric playset from ram
jack all the back alley action the dark
streets and some stranger with a hungry
hunter world random
so all that 1/32 scale my contact and
lock eyes got it now make the blocker
and check the hanky code RAM Jack's real
digital readout controller
cross-reference with real life
up-to-date handkerchief signals
watersports you've got a time it just
right there you've got him no it's just
some guy dressed like a cop the cruising
electric play set additional strangers
sold separately don't do dads Larry
you're too bad you're too dads put it
together
Jarvis send me that this morning and
that's you sent it to me
Randall sent me like what is wrong with
my life that this gay video has been
sent to me seven times in one week they
said you're too dad daddy let's look at
more hot [ __ ] tells you to do something
doesn't mean you have to do it yeah look
up most gorgeous dicks why Hey why
wasn't friend of show making all on that
list Oh
Weidman is at the top of the list let's
all go around the table and say would
you let Mickey go [ __ ] him I'll go first
yes definitely absolutely that's four
yes is Mickey come on Auburn load us up
with hot dick the real question is if
you wanted to could you stop oh yeah
wait if you want to [ __ ] you're
getting [ __ ] you wanna get [ __ ] bro no
he was not a bunch drug sports we're
[ __ ] [ __ ] he would definitely have to
take you either get [ __ ] without your
arm broken or you get [ __ ] with your arm
broken
[Laughter]
this is all about boner
oh just hurts me stuff that's unnatural
your bodies have been yeah yes get in
that position Johnny whoever said that
on your errand I'd like to stress it's
not a Johnny and Aaron in that same
position yes no seriously before the
podcast is over we can we please of
course every week for an hour like that
you're on it's like then we'll talk we
gotta make it no I know because it's
gonna be an hour right let's get all the
other sports out no I agree I just want
to remind we're gonna talk some NBA
sport but that's the second out okay
okay so for nine minutes you should talk
baseball 300 base talk baseball
I mean his marriage is wrecked might as
well give him something but that minute
Valley the Michael is still inside your
Nicholas absolutely ridiculous it is
weird right Spira see right hand me
Kimbrough well they're both they're both
Scott Boras clients so that's a big
thing is he blacklisted I mean damn
those are two top-line dudes like the
Darger's could use them both we don't
read oh yes we do we don't for the
postseason you know you trust that
bullpen you know Scott Alexander like I
mean I love these dude dude I mean we
probably a looser closer because he
Mackin [ __ ] at the mall but no Yuri
is not the closest justice I'll walk you
played five more games in the Cubs
chances because they play indoors they
don't get rained out oh yeah that's
right course no divorce no doubt yeah
that because the beginning of season of
a snow and every day in Chicago damn we
got the best record though and the Cubs
no no you guys got three more yeah but
you've also played more games well the
girls have a better winning
oh the Cubs are doing well now they were
[ __ ] the bed now they're killing
they have a better dad they were
starting the season [ __ ] in the bat I
mean three and three it's good I mean I
know it was worse because of
6:32 ba da just playing 628 but I'll
take first I'll take first
they've also played our games in us too
for us it's about two postseason -
regular C for both of ball teams ball TV
October mud tell something if Andrew
Freeman's listeners podcast and we know
he does okay I don't want to make it to
the World Series unless we have a
[ __ ] top-shelf rotation I don't wanna
be I very well your bills
you won't boop whoa make it to the World
Series without a good rotational bullpen
you got we got a strength in the bullpen
man that's that's what kills us we got
starters man is this the [ __ ] pen you
know I mean like where you going Johnny
why are you walking out when you're
talking about your [ __ ] Braves that
suck yeah I don't want that I do I'd
love to play a little water sports with
Johnny let him tinkle all over me dude
what do you got a yellow handkerchief
which is hankie make eye contact bro
make hard eye contact I know um
the Dodgers are great for the best ever
I mean obviously we're [ __ ] great
regular-season no we are turning into
the bill as a baseball though that's
dead we can you know dude it's like I
mean like they didn't get
what's-his-face for Houston that
destroyed us two years ago
Overlander yeah we could've gotten oh
dude they want give up urea Swede you
not give up your ES for [ __ ]
Verlander well if we had one it would
have been you would have been worth it
but I mean your ass is a key part yo yo
[ __ ] World Series now I would like I
would like to dodge this who've gotten
Verlander just to see Kate Upton
understands every night man and that
means they wouldn't have had him
committee her dick ass blowout soon as
that baby come but it's re gone [ __ ]
flew out back did she hurt her body back
that [ __ ] has a [ __ ] kid hey dude my
bed my bed that's right that's right
oh now it is for the second our second
our buddy knows a sports fan we'll be
back next week why is he coming this
week I don't know you told me last night
that he couldn't make it today yeah yeah
but it's convenient right that's [ __ ]
convenient he's too busy dancing with
his car it's great right
I think they already beat you to the
point
I'm talking them about putting weed in
their mushrooms in there and one with a
crystal meth I think that is natural I
like it you name like all natural stuff
you like I want one with bath salts in
it
Oh that'd be the best and no coffee just
a can of basalt yeah no it's good like
this
these snort bath salts who do smoke them
Jason in your in your eyes I do all I
slam it Qi right into my eye I'd take a
needle right into my eye
oh yeah and then I make a [ __ ] dildo
out of bath salts and just [ __ ] no
it's a it's a like a suppository but
it's shaped like a guy's for an answer
basketball Hanako no I need to see Kate
Upton's post baby buddy Johnny I need to
see Kate
yes we got four minutes left Johnny okay
you look at Kate Upton's
debauchery and we need to seek a UPS in
a recent picture
Kate Upton at had baby it's big Cape
baseball talk Aaron it's Kate Upton a.g
married to a baby vagina
post birth oh you want to see the baby
oh my god you got a cute baby Kate
Upton's blown out clam no look at the
second one she might have had a
c-section though so it looks like she
had a double
all I wanted was the sushi at a tiny
waist again yeah what is it I wanted to
judge about it that you cream coz that
body tends to be built for black guys we
went ruined it with a white guy thank
you
hey still holla at me k how many
followers does she have how many more Oh
Ronaldo was six million her but another
[ __ ] what's her [ __ ] dumb face has
like 30 million to to two men still NBA
basketball oh what's this called that's
called [ __ ] everybody's gangbang and
guy came up it that's a Super Bowl she's
a [ __ ] she's in [ __ ] 44 we came up
there
this one's called you dick [ __ ] Jews
are gonna bleed up on Caleb came beat
off on Kate Upton [ __ ] face [ __ ]
44 two minutes till basketball talk how
many kids do they have just one just the
one why she would two kids was she's
stealing somebody's kid whose [ __ ]
kid is that or nice Johnny sounds like
you've been was always free to do this
yeah Oh get some of that nitro shy about
breastfeeding or I cover up like very
extremely I was like yeah I have like a
blanket is actually my nursing bras I'm
like nobody's allowed to see them until
basketball talk one minute let's just
talk basketball instead oh what let's
just count to 60 and then we'll go one
minute oh look at that hard workout
she's putting the word putting in the
[ __ ] work dude these need to be this
kind of [ __ ] out hot no you gotta put
in the word he's in the kitchen cooking
that [ __ ] up she's got three trainers
telling her what to do
just to faith did that okay as a black
guy who sweats all the time yelling at
her like a drill sergeant blaming Gabe
man telling her how fear she is yeah and
then she has I mean whatever she's doing
it's working yeah okay one minute to get
that [ __ ] k I need a big window to work
out that beaut oh that's a green screen
look at these guys it is time guys guys
today's sports and B a basketball talks
brought to you by our good friends at
bet D s I bet the acai for all of your
betting needs music oh tinfoil hat music
promo code punch 25 and you will get $25
Ben cash now let's say you just want to
make a one-time bet don't opt into the
bonus just make your bet if you opt into
the bonus you got a bet so much money to
get your money back because if you let's
say you put $500 in and they match that
$500 now you got $1,000 you pulled out
they lose $500 so you got a bet so much
but if you wanna help out the podcast
you wanna help it out go and to bet
deicide comm use the promo code punch 25
and make them bets dude whatever you
whatever you put in they will double up
to 500 bucks but that is choosing the
bonus if you want to get paid out right
away if let's say you bet 225 you win
cool there's weight fifty out or you
cannot do the bonus and just put in the
next 100 bucks and they won't double it
and if you win you can take your money
out right then yeah good if you want
them to double it you got to leave your
money in and keep yeah I do it's a bonus
man get the bone it's the bone and put
some magic Raymond I'm gonna be playing
rock out [ __ ] so you gonna be playing
anyway you're gonna be playing anyway
you're pleasuring fan you're not to kind
of put your obviously gambling with your
life right yeah so you might as well
I'll take the bonus and roll it out
throughout the rest of the playoffs
yeah bet on everything dude NBA playoffs
is we got baseball parlay on the horse
right in but dude we're thinking about
if these games go far maybe
you and I get on a plane and go watch
some NBA games playoff yeah dude and you
know wet on the Bachelorette
well you know we're gonna use C key guys
that's right Oh feet tied all together
geek
all right you a promo code punch right
punch drunk and you get $10 off your
first ticket
I'm gonna go concerts are coming dodgers
are coming Jonas Brothers are coming
okay right there San Diego Padres right
there Dodgers versus Padres $10 that's a
free ticket more your e-ticket warriors
playing warriors come out and play
I'd like to see Portland take it to the
Warriors man I'd like to see it watch
that I won't go watch that diamond light
it up dude come on Dynes light it up
James damn Darla Dane's Dallas and CJ
and we're gonna go buy our tix go find
out what go Do's find out what playoff
tickets in San Francisco cost like a
billion dollars
Oh guys pink a-pink's gonna be a Don't
Tell run is easy yeah let's call runs
easy tell him Pink's coming I heard he
cried it the last time you saw them is
that true Danny yeah well he said he was
pulling over at the he was denying it
when I was talking to you we could do
that a hundred that's not that expensive
I thought they were gonna be I granted
you're probably sitting in the way back
on the moon he's not that many bad seats
in the Oracle though the tickets go to
oxygen tank
but that's dude for a playoff game this
would be way more expensive in LA oh of
course
do you know that's washable that's
manageable well I bet that's a regular
that's a regular season ticket for the
Lakers yeah and they didn't make a play
Oh buy your tickets dude siegy we should
go buy our tickets on Tiki use a code
punch drunk and then throw money on it
on Betty si use the code punch 25 man I
love sea kick win your money back win
your money back
thank you you get money out you got a
break on your ticket price and then you
win your money back by betting yeah and
you know what go to blue to use a code
punch drunk and watch this game rock
hard yeah dude get get your bloop to go
goodbye
make your bet and then get a ticket rock
and drink a caveman coffee nitro your
way to the game where is that go see if
you can find that UFC is supposed to be
in Orange County
yeah down in Anaheim August 17th August
17 Anaheim is it there is it there is it
there
never release tickets but you might not
go we can we can sell your ticket yeah
you can sell see you know we thank you
dude dude you're the best dude you're
killing us
and that was MBA talk punch-drunk
Packers charges already $300
oh no the Packers do it like that no
that's the charges that's that little
minor stadium well that too but the
Packers they did that when they played
the round they they buy up all them tick
uh-huh people trying to get out of Green
Bay but ya know this talk NBA playoffs
Houston shot themselves in the foot
thanks for bringing your attention to it
right I know
fans love that right oh [ __ ] look at
that face you know I was just thinking
nevermind right that's the serial killer
phase two is way too expensive he's
leaving because of more tinfoil hat
Consuela
what do you mean that made family oh
that's a plug for tinfoil hat and that's
all he does right that's a that made Sam
have to boo-boo
right also it's probably like something
in his personal life and he's just like
crazy conspiracy gotta go well why don't
are we waiting for Sam for NBA time we
should just sit here in silence
ya know what's that start to do our
Bible verses because this is the
Christian hour yeah we we should do that
we should do like a punch-drunk trip to
UFC and you know garnets gonna be there
hey I am Muslim holidays garnet my dad
just bought a fake it
he sent me a thing that was like that
fight was gonna be in Anaheim like
they're like the minute they were
Center to me and then I could see that
he was typing and then I go he's
literally I said to my friend I was in
the car with and I got I go he's
literally gonna say looks like I'll be
going there him and then like when it
popped up it goes almost word for word
exactly what I said he was gonna say
garnet is my dude a great guy very got
me oh yeah I've [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
that guy I'd let him inside of me so
quick find me a nude I see what I mean
by a little a Jeff there though but I
want to see a picture this guy's Wang
and I'll tell you is that the same guy I
mean I'd spoon fuck'em but I wouldn't
make love to him Tebow is a yes it looks
like it's trying to suck his own dick
right there and that kind of does turn
me on guys I think I'm gay your sexual
this is really on the male side women so
sick of window we just coming to this
conclusion you want to get you want me
to suck your dick I'm talking to you bro
[Laughter]
although that guy I would love that if
Casper came out here it's Casper if you
come out here I will let you [ __ ] me and
also suck your [ __ ] [ __ ] so sweet
he's like never going Casper you have my
word if you come out here I'll suck you
sideways like a harmonica yeah hey
where's that do from who Casper no the
dude that he was he put this out I don't
really like it Wells Cox
yes you do yeah you're right [ __ ] it
I'll [ __ ] your [ __ ] faces special
[ __ ] oh that's his club team though let
them wail on my [ __ ] if you know I'm
saying guys thanks Johnny
oh you took your expression off I was
like wait a minute is that today were
you taking okay we need a we need a gay
sponsor so cut into a Tom time like neat
noob but just for buttholes
dude stuff okay first of all about this
last night me and Johnny we're does
quite Leonard shot falling the greatest
shots of all time
I think it's 67 it's still TBD it's
still to be determined it got this run
has to turn into something if they lose
in the next round it's not one of the
greatest shots ever so Dan tossed I
think they have to turn into something
old I gave this key me like so what was
that shot for if they don't you know I
mean if they don't at least get to the
fine I mean this Carter had a shot like
that
yeah missed it I thought he made it
knowing but 15 years ago no he missed it
and that's why everybody's going crazy
okay so this was a regime that shot and
this was the redemption yeah I don't
know I still feel it has to turn into
something no so you think it's one of
the greatest shots all-time if they just
go out well I mean let Johnny will you
find that list that you were talking
about last night where all the greatest
shots of all time that looked like it
went into me there was there was a there
was but no it was one where he was with
the Raptors yeah and he missed it
right no but this one went in this is
Vince making but not so you think it's
one of the greatest shots like you know
Tom hi
had that one for the Celtics that
bounced and when I do yeah but this one
about four times no no but I'm saying
that one was like in the Chairman let's
power right let's go let's throw out he
has a list right here greatest playoff
shots of MBA put an MBA put an MBA
ringer greatest shots I mean one has to
be jordan against Utah all right Jordan
against Utah Jordan against Craig Ehlo
oh yeah that was also K Derek Fisher
point one four or he had at least Mori
Kyrie has I revived I think number one
is Ray Allen's Tom Heinsohn has won yo
the one that bounced up see I'm not I'm
not that old like that but but I hate
how people don't even consider the old
school [ __ ] no we are I'm saying for the
minute Jerry West at a half-court shot
right okay like that kind of [ __ ] I feel
like that has to be in there Oh magic
against the Celtics yeah hook yeah
when creamy cream is hurt any other play
center when they finally beat the
Celtics in Boston Garden and nobody what
about the Globetrotters do you know that
that is my first NBA moment I remember
like actually being like whoa was
watching that game and watching Magic
Johnson do the [ __ ] baby hook and I
remember going oh this is important I'm
raspberry what year was that dude 88 87
88 no no Patrick Ewing come in 90 I
think no no no no no no why are you and
within the mid-80s but yeah probably
like 80 Ewing was drafted what you 86 is
my guess okay when was the baby hook by
magic to beat the boss himself
I was like 88 89 87 at the earliest
because 84 we lost to this we got swept
by the Sixers that's my first real
was that does it say okay so obviously
that wasn't my first memory so I
apologize 84 we got swept by the Sixers
when it falls my first memory of the NBA
was when Blake Griffin got traded to
Detroit but I drink a lot haha
no but Patrick Ewing the reason I love
basketball
really yes oh and that's probably why
you pick teams like that he never won
I remember swimmer ease of the NBA
really I mean so I was a Bulls fan
before Jordan yeah but like only for
like a year or two the Orlando Woolridge
did Lander Wooldridge Bob loved all that
kind of Grandville waiters oh wow those
guys and then they go somewhere and then
they got Jordan when I was in sixth
grade and then it was just on like you
did not miss a Bulls game no he'd be
coming back then that's like cable
wasn't even really super huge like Gumby
like five channels and WGA was one of
them and they used to show the bull yep
everybody had five channels so every
Bulls game that was on game blouses look
he's like games that's Paul Westphal oh
that's not Paul Westphal oh that's a
great shot
i ball Tom Heinsohn where's Tom Tom
Heinsohn has one yo-yo that was with the
tap out that's [ __ ] sweaty or he hit
a lot or you I mean three different
teams he's gotten black buzzer yeah yeah
I mean is really one argument that I
hate Famer my big probably one argument
that I hate and people do it in football
as well and you don't like hey man he
may be like Dan Marino never won a
[ __ ] Super Bowl so he sucks it's like
it's a team sport doesn't suck because
if you make that argument Robert Horry
is the best NBA player in the history of
time ya know I've got more rings than
anybody well Moses Russell Russell I
think the ring and that's when there was
four teams and the only black guy in the
NOC and that's the thing again
here we go with the history how people
do the history because actually Bill
Russell played against great comp yo
like they put the numbers up with that
one year it was one year where Bill
Russell won an MVP Oscar averaged a
triple-double will average like 40 and
20 like the numbers that year that was
one one year in the 60s like the people
Brussels played against yo the logo I'm
saying
Chamberlain Oscar I mean the 60s was
loaded Russell wasn't out there against
nobody I'm especially Pete the 70s
Pistol Pete might have been the 70s but
now it's actually he was the first white
chocolate no he was great 70 to 80 oh
yeah yeah okay so he played college ball
in the sixties no the 60s was the people
still sleeping on the 60 you would be
you would you can make the NBA in the
1960s no yes
Oscar Robinson Jerry West Elgin Baylor
Bill Russell Wilt Chamberlain never
heard of him best of all time five of
the 60s Shawn Kemp was all 90s and he's
not in the end of in the Hall of Fame
that's great I can't was not John
Stockton Jordan Barkley car Malone and
the dream that's first team Oh an entire
team he's was that sterile team yeah
he's like he's like there's 15 guys on
the team okay I document top five I'm
just listing the top five per decade but
now there's always been a part of me in
all sports that I'm like I mean it's the
Hall of Fame that big of a [ __ ] deal
yes yeah I mean to me no for me - I'd
rather win championships and have a nice
long career and you know I mean there's
so many people you like that guys ship
in in the hall table yeah but it's like
it's so political heroes deserve to be
in the Hall of Fame well that's cuz he
bet on the game yeah but does he deserve
to be in the Hall of Fame absolutely
first balli he would have been in 30
years ago if he hadn't got caught
betting mmm
here it is sister Jerry was at the forum
at the Great Western forum when ah and
the thing is that was a - cuz there's no
three-point line hilarious yeah that
tied to gave it one or two that was a -
yo that should have been the MTV 25
pointer remember that oh yeah
nobody ever remembers that [ __ ] oh défis
had a couple yeah I mean like that's a
great shot - I mean like that's up there
but I think Weis definitely I mean I
look at that score
look at that [ __ ] score what about
Brad Williams in the all-star game
right where's that in here yeah I'm with
you dude
that [ __ ] hit it see how do they not D
up Brad Williams I don't know dude like
I feel like blast him out he's like oh
this is how Kawhi shots gonna end up if
they don't win anything like this Alonzo
Mourning game winner like that's how we
go and remember people forget about
Alonzo Mourning right exactly this is
such a great team look this is how
co-wives is gonna be like you know I
mean we're gonna look at that's such a
great team but do you really remember
that I miss grandma MA I meant of course
it does he's from Charlotte you miss
Mugsy no I don't miss the miss I like
Mugsy more than grandmama you do [ __ ]
you man that's Larry Johnson just my
opinion well your opinion sucks hey
fight nanny and join the NBA talk noble
Dame Dame shot and Kauai shot could go
down if either one of those teams make
us along like if if Portland wins it you
know I mean that dang shot and if
Toronto at least gets to the fun my
favorite famous was this oh my favorite
part is in the melee after the look he
gave the camera he was like he didn't
smile nothing quite still of that shot
that was nice twice squatting like an
Asian him and MB then his buddies trying
to get in the shotgun oh [ __ ]
hit me in beter just looking up at like
you know when like in the beginning of a
game and they do all the announcements
and you know they have all the unlike
the Jumbotron they show all the players
when they're announcing anybody go down
to the bottom go down to the word yeah
yeah that where everybody's looking look
at the picture of everybody's faces
that's actually not the last one because
the guys in squatting near Kauai there's
one where the guys right next to Kauai
and he's like damn the whole thing dude
there I don't know where that picture is
it's usually everywhere
I love Toronto I loved there that's all
right that's hilarious
right whoo what's up with donovan mcnabb
somehow getting down there and [ __ ]
getting in the picture I mean come on
the boy is that guy the ball bounce so
much that they had a chance to do that
yeah that [ __ ] went in like the end of
one of those bad basketball movies or
like when they play basketball on Fresh
Prince of bel-air yeah Kauai is is
sitting like Asian see when they smoke
and look at his tongue he's challenges
inner Jordan ot Frye right right yeah
like did I say it is yeah exactly
why isn't Teen Wolf in the Hall of Fame
that guy could dunk Annie he's a
werewolf
that's hilarious he said [ __ ] like
that's how this movie would end with the
ball going in like that yes there ha ha
ha first of all that's travel by the way
that's Michael Jefferson ball he travels
right there's likely on ecstasy he did
so much e in the 90s oh he was just just
just do eat all the time is that true
yeah they think that's a big reason why
I got Parkinson's cuz I thought it was
because of Oprah dude that whole
generation of the 80s they were doing
draw
like nothing's gonna happen they were
just like Mitzi Robin Williams oh wow
Richard Pryor we're doing like ice cream
scoops of cocaine
they were just coking and just [ __ ]
frying their their nervous system and
that's why they all got [ __ ] the get
get get get get he said they were doing
ice cream scoops okay yeah I could
totally see that yo he said that's why
they're all [ __ ] up a simple mass love
that you're doing play-by-play on our
conversation this you know cause it's
just thinking in like [ __ ] like a bee on
me it makes sense that we see these
people deteriorate and die and we never
put it together that a there's a history
behind this way back when everybody was
just it was cool like you would do coke
at church like people are doing daggers
in church do you know I was cool I mean
the [ __ ] priest is [ __ ] rubbing
his [ __ ] lips with Tonka the Lord
loves just like nothing it's not cool
now who jumps when they should have free
Thor - there's so many things that
gravels who officiated that goddamn team
okay but why [ __ ] when he do nothing he
was like this is my big break
I just farted hard what are you doing
bro court McCown they're number 33 yes
Cormac that is quorum account yes court
look how good look at course feel good
looking then not yes
I never said karma count that is oh
really
auntie wolf I was in the gay porn
preteen wolf
check me out you're 33 - I was I play I
played 33 travel travel stands up with
the ball and jumps travel he just came
out of that pilot some [ __ ] wolf came
out Armenian dog he went into the powers
of white dude okay watch watch watch all
these violations came out from Glendale
just the last play of the game it's all
carry carries right there oh wow cork it
back in the day he's good-looking well
he's on the Beavers you don't look like
a beauty that's insanely hot do you know
how hard it's just to give that role to
be like whoa that's a wolf can use
what's a wolf look well it's a wolf
oh look at this this is for gang oh he's
a good dog might be good court again
he's like wow laughter that guy's he's
still life isn't the guy know right he's
a door guy at the store he looks like
every door guy at the store that isn't
Fang Chow that the fat guy from the 80s
is still alive okay looks like Wang like
a white whomp is that your dad
give me that oh thank you yeah I'm still
I'm ripping core court was highly
feature yeah dude I know I'm Armenian
what are you guys turk [ __ ] you quark
the court key gets IMDB for this yeah
you every time this is played he gets a
pension so we're making yeah
just keep playing making him baby over
again dude over and over courts gonna
get sick of course MTV remade this and
made it homoerotic right right
oh yeah no way bear nobody cares they
can't make it homoerotic enough if you
ask me I know a Tebow's seen it Tebow
seen it so let's go through the the
remaining playoff series
we have Toronto vs. Milwaukee who do you
guys think Winston
I think Milwaukee wins it actually
pretty comfortably really I'm thinking
six months yeah I'll save him the
Lockean five they definitely have the
better team for sure they're starting
five versus they're starting five yeah
walk he has the better starting five and
I mean what Toronto showed me in that
game seven like it pretty much came down
to Kauai like he had no help and they
went 7 games Milwaukee is gonna be
fresher
I think Milwaukee me I think Milwaukee
just has more dudes like if yawning in
hot dudes know like which team would you
like to [ __ ] the most Oh which starting
five would you like to Richie would you
like right nany the blow bang go wrong
why does she get to he it's on the water
I think he bows to do it thank sure by
the white Tebow tonight he's off his uh
his trans walk I be late Scotty maybe
even a little later oh no I have an 8
o'clock table read for a [ __ ] cartoon
film I'm doing okay that's a legit
excuse okay and alright saving stuff
that goes to ten from Santa Monica to
you guys then get ready
we know oh it's gonna be [ __ ] gross
so do it
what do you wanna do about this turn it
down ask all everybody's doing this and
not to the table read gross girls girls
girls so yeah we got Milwaukee over boss
over Toronto so 11 o'clock at Sycamore
tavern 11 o'clock Sycamore yeah okay dad
I could play polo the lemon is good so
[ __ ] gross what do you want to do
you're gross what do you want me to do
Krause quit it yeah I'll shove an email
well do a random job well I mean problem
I hope I hope it goes cuz it's not doing
this back but I'm saying podcast I said
it do it today I just say it has to be
late
alright man your 11:00 is cool 11:00 I
can make I told the makeup artist can we
do we do
just put on pretty red lips we can write
there are you gonna shave guys the deal
I think it's funny with the beard no all
right go on who do you got no yeah you
have to we we said I'm gonna go
Milwaukee I go man how many I think it's
gonna be a little long I think it might
go seven oh really yeah I think it's
gonna be quick enough I think we all
agree they know is like Marc Gasol Kawhi
Leonard Danny Green they've all have a
lot more playoff experience than then
the Milwaukee Bucks team yeah but what
happened to those dudes in the game
seven I didn't see cool danny green or
marc gasol pedro siakam was playing like
he had clinched buttcheeks I just feel
like it felt it came down to Kauai only
and if it's like that it gets Milwaukee
that's not gonna be enough okay all
right all right so fight anything Aries
is pretty easy
perfect perfect that's it's a West
though Wes that's we're going else is
what's the other that's it that's it oh
dude it's so funny one looks like his
mom one looks like his dad
I mean I'm absolutely the other one's a
decent-looking guy
I'm absolutely pulling of course for the
Trailblazers you know I don't think they
have a shot you'll think they have a
shot I think they have a shot no they
have a shot definitely and if KD
the longer KD is out the more of a shot
they have right if it becomes a gorian
you would say that about Houston to but
no no it doesn't have anything my killer
Chris Paul isn't what he used me Chris
Paul James Harden and D'Antoni have all
shown as they they can't get it done I
never can't all be the number one guy on
your thing I never look at that Steph
Curry looks like his mom [ __ ] seth
Curry looks like his dad
South Korea's but [ __ ] ugly okay and
guess who he wants to marry who Doc
Rivers daughter oh wow she's had a train
of [ __ ] just MBA dick in her yeah
he's like I wanna make you an honest
woman what side day okay okay that's the
sister yeah because she's a chick all
right if he has a vagina yeah you
[ __ ] Reggie a Steph Curry had a
vagina we would be like this is Steph
Curry's daughter gonna be a monster yes
you've not rather [ __ ] Steph Curry than
this trollop that one female comic
what's her name yeah who's she what
rapper she dating where - who do we like
in the way this author the audio this is
us looking at photos that no one can
even understand what do we like in the
West
I want Portland [ __ ] I'm like
Portland's gonna give up a better fight
than I'm ruining the Portland more than
anything cuz Portland has the ability to
get in play go like like like the
Warriors know exactly if Duran is out
and it becomes a gar game Steph and klay
against dame and McCullough that's a
closer than people do you think right my
buddy's band you know when they do the
intros and they show everything on the
jumbotron my buddy's band
it's their song that they do what's it
called [ __ ] are over Manuel Portugal
the man I don't know who they are they
do that in Portland they're from
Portland I mean they play that yeah
uh-huh
yeah no I'm rolling with the Blazers man
I think they got a puncher's chance
especially if Durant is out yeah I
definitely want him to win how do you
think Gerrans feeling about all this
talk about they're better without him
please he knows that's not true you know
it's not true I've heard him in that
interview you know who I am
y'all know who I am he's he's the
difference left like of all the team
Steph Curry is the is the ghost in the
machine without Steph Curry that team's
just the OKC Thunder when totally
totally Curry's the difference we saw
them what a big hurry in the last series
play
when he wanted to against Houston no
cadiz thank you back whenever he's out
that team is mortal no okay
Cady's yeah most unstoppable player in
the league yeah look up look up the
Warriors record without KD I look up
Warriors record without Steph Curry I
don't care about that I'm about in a
poster you hear about facts
no I'm saying look that's gonna be
regular season numbers I'm talking about
in the postseason when the money is on
the line
I want KD over stuff any day oh is KD
staying it with the Warriors I don't
know dude they thinking you might want
to go to New York why ah Warriors are 21
when Steph Curry plays without ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha the coincidence is no one
cares in the regular I do they have a
mall I dude I'm having Dana go by me all
my favorite players jerseys I'm getting
Rasheed Wallace I want Shawn Kemp's
Jersey I have Michael Jordan's Jersey I
have Allen Iverson's Georgia I have
Patrick Ewing seriously no Clippers no I
have all the Clippers I have every
savior we've had since 2000 ok Elton
Brand
I gave him Shaun Livingston I got a
dodgeball why would I have a Doc Rivers
because he was on the last time they
made the plant will not last night when
they were good with the sale go on what
he's haymaker sale that would be dope
yeah I mean dude I mean I mean Steph
Curry is if he wins a championship right
now what he start talking about right
moving on what me all-time greats he's
not and he's not an all-time or not dude
you are losing all no way so would it
what is he top 10 if he wins this one he
starts talking about so where does that
put Duran Duran sup there - dude I'm
telling rent is higher than stay on no
no Nanette
the real tired and Stefan Eva is never
one without Steph Curry Steph Curry's
one without Kevin Durant it's a fact
jack no you're right
ok thank you that's real doesn't hold
him a better player three words JJ
reddick that's good I think I think the
Warriors are gonna pick them up it's
possibly they're gonna be trash next
year no no I mean I mean for the finals
okay
can I say the words are gonna be trash
katie is gonna be in LA
no he's where I don't know in LA it's
it's two teams in LA you do you art dude
in one minute 20 minutes span you have
destroyed all your basketball
credibility no I want to take your black
card right now because you're saying
suddenly tarted [ __ ] keep talking dumb
[ __ ] like this and I'm not gonna suck
your dick anymore you're right well I'm
saying so you're saying he maybe he goes
to [ __ ] Brooklyn cuz they got a much
better team than than the Knicks but I
lose I'm losing my credibility but he's
going to the Nets he's going to next
they're gonna get Zion as well they'll
get Zion as well they're going to the
Knicks are gonna be the Lakers are gonna
get Zion guy as much as I want your [ __ ]
in my mouth you just [ __ ] yourself
there bro look at that we got a 2%
chance man hey dude where the weather
Bulls on that 12 Ranger fine but I think
they go he goes into you that's the
lottery chances right that's the least
he's not going to today oh god the Bulls
would be great that's too low
now of where Durant goes for time oh oh
oh oh I mean then you're just doing that
right there have you ever done backbend
no I have not
you're just doing that right there right
have no you're betting on who means a
lot of it we only get one team and if he
doesn't go to either team we use a bunch
neither one of them I'll give you the
field
oh I take that all day long no no no no
wait wait wait so confident I'll take
three teams NYX and three teams okay
you get three teams and if none of them
make it then it's discipline if all four
don't make it it doesn't nobody has
passed right all right so you got the
names of course I'm going with the
Lakers okay what are you doing bro make
you shut up makers chow Lakers Cavs okay
and bull's eye got Lakers calves and
bulls and you got the Knicks and what
now what's the bet to find out oh my god
nanny Paul she's the only one the crane
can read and I'm so [ __ ] thirsty for
hot [ __ ] in my mouth I can't even focus
we always get this one it's always the
shock ball caller give me is that the
only one it's in there that one fight
nanny does not want that go pull again
Lakers until someone does it we're doing
it now June I next week by two weeks why
can't we still do alive I know it's all
it's that I'm [ __ ] I don't like that
that's why I wear when I talk or make
any noise I get shocked which is what
you deserve what did you order is the
bed get remote control oh okay okay I
really like this one and it fits with
our theme and it fits with their
sponsors use from beyondblue chill and
it's yoga Onvia
and it's at least a one-hour class okay
I'm definitely I wanna be in that class
I'm coming cuz I want to laugh I might
do that either way don't say the B word
it's it's blue chill yoga on blue chill
I may be that well either way yeah my oh
my
that will win or lose and Bulls I'm
thinking Lakers make this is my first
choice but that's so easy
I think leave what were you saying
Johnny you should go Neil in Phoenix
Chicago well I mean I got to order three
yeah
but the Lakers have a - year's NBA oh
the NBA wants to die on in LA you know
are we saying who drafts him or where
does he find up who wins the draft
lottery know who wins tonight which of
our four teams wins the balls to nine
okay if they trade him down the road
that doesn't yeah tonight you say the
Knicks and I say Cavs Bulls or Lakers
that's that's it what time is the
lottery tonight 8:30 it's game tonight
right [ __ ] this games tonight are they
are they both both games aren't on the
same night right there one night one
night where are the NBA's just gonna
laughter two months right right right
yeah it will last two months I'm [ __ ]
nervous for what that's an easiest bet
in the world to pay off you got to take
out yoga class got it you're gonna be
hard in the class anyway
I'll double down take - you got to take
a yoga class a one-hour yoga class
what a terrible bad Onvia on liuchiu you
have to take it before the clock not
like with the second you walk in I want
you guys to take it let our boy be
kicking it I need to see we've all taken
a blue - today I'm hard during a podcast
oh you got a stretch out I could see you
being like okay what a terrible
hey that's what got pulled man what a
horrific that I do it I feel really bad
for you guys to have to take a one-hour
I like it I don't even know that stupid
one got even in the better remember that
B oh boy wait put in there you gotta
make a phone call you got a call a
pretty girl put that in the bag to
control nobody wanted to do them anymore
we gotta take paid off is advanced you
know what you would die in a yoga class
the stuff actually it's so easy no I'm
just saying you have to get in those
positions that we just saw that girl
stretching you should have to take a
yoga class with a butt plug in make sure
it doesn't fall out like really clinched
it 18 minutes and be eight we haven't
gotten or four times why do we never
talk about the go let's go let's go
calls no we do this - oh there it is the
miss one there we go play the one that
Garnett go up there it is Garnett put
one word they play him side by side
Casper I gotta let you know Elmo I'm
already letting you know I'm stealing
that pick right there no I like it yeah
but he was in the bathroom yeah okay
yeah this is the one that Vince mrs.
Kasper told me he went to Instagram he
went to Instagram on his break
Casper tattle
oh you remember this why that was so big
because Vince Carter had gone to his
graduation and they're like you got folk
he's like hey dude I'm not gonna play
game forever
I want [ __ ] you know I won't be able to
walk when I'm done and I was game
forever back next year yes he is our age
I'm saying he said that 30 years ago
[ __ ] for that 30 years ago he said he
wasn't playing this game forever
yeah and he's playing this game you go
up look it but why not go up go up more
go oh I love about one of you down down
down down that one that's me in the
[ __ ] the Britney Spears Britney
Spears video that was such a good time
remember that such a good time we never
heard that story can you tell us the
story God talk about your baby all the
[ __ ] time never do and I don't bring
it up like your baby it's not true
this is punch-drunk Instagram yeah
that's all we do we post words [ __ ]
words half right there was just dead
silence for a minute Jason you didn't
talk at the beginning of I'm doing what
we're all doing looking at Johnny
looking at the internet the best podcast
in the world welcome to Johnny looking
at the Internet the hot podcast hey you
guys you know my Johnny Cash shirt where
he's like throwing up the mail finger
that's the black version of it right
there yeah okay you want to be right
shirts I'm gonna start narrating what
we're doing he's wearing a Richard Pryor
shirt since nobody knows what the [ __ ]
were talking about all right all right
all right
so before I got here before your caveman
kicked in you were silent yeah he's very
quiet and then you're like I suck ha ha
right if you want to suck a nice [ __ ]
Rock large drop in nitro
hey kid music okay like when we do know
he doesn't like when we say that there's
heroin and or okay I was suggesting you
weren't saying there is yeah hey dude if
it sells product we'll do whatever we
gotta do
y'all taking tall's yeah we're all
making fun yet we're taking tall all
really fight nanny you are no better
about yourself I say all the time you
pronouncing names is my favorite thing
about units endearing and adore yeah I'm
gonna light hard okay I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I like it why do you like it so
much
no no cuz it's entertaining unity oh
shoot we got call here we go why'd you
hang up this Jeb it's gotta be the only
person to calls why say one call in
anymore that you should be the best part
we don't say to do it though there's
only three people watching us live so
garnet Jeb Caspar call us we literally
don't know there's five of us in a room
and we're watching the sixth guy on the
internet so good deal 101 guys guys
we'll see you soon
why yeah started 12 minutes late oh that
is early for us Oh what scream want to
talk about cream what do you want to
talk about the NBA Draft
oh no we talked about the draft lottery
so how about this actual play let's talk
about the Lakers and how people turned
on the Lakers gig to take the Phoenix
Suns gig well confirm they were gonna
give it to tyloo that's why he took that
because tyloo was supposed to get it
then we couldn't [ __ ] finalize the
negotiations we talked to lowball tyloo
you still not even know what I'm saying
no we have [ __ ] Frank Vogel and
that's why I was saying that's my thing
we don't have a plan if they had hired
tyloo then that could have been like
okay we're trying to make LeBron happy
but Vogel was never one of the top all
right we got a call hello you're on with
puncturing sports
calling from Texas how are you yeah
that's what I want to see keep Johnny
hey how's it going hey I don't know
y'all talked about this it's any
presents and ideas right dude I thought
we talked about a little bit apparently
I mean you never know what those both of
those guys last time he was justified
poori it didn't have an ounce in tickets
or saddest always gets hurt and you
never know what [ __ ] Diaz things have
turned it around a little bit am i right
a little bit
I mean couple fights he's good I mean it
goes without saying that we're all pro
Diaz right we're pro Diaz because one of
us both his cousin his brother what I
could see myself owning as cousin before
I like to be like I'll get bone in you
the world champion who the world champ
Mike Tyson Nate does happen in time dude
I'm good where you in Texas Austin okay
why Mubeen Houston and Dallas soon so
come hang out rent a car bro I'll come
down to the air control hat I'll see you
next year
Houston Eddie Bravo Bravo well use the
Cody and Oh pick a discount don't do it
all right all right
thanks for taking the call guys America
you know that guy loves American boners
that's what that guy loves mr. rock-hard
American boners and it takes to chew
he'll have one yeah take the to get that
boner make love
that all-american ass dog okay so Johnny
brought this up right here these are
prospects yes let's just say the Lakers
stay out of the 10 slide we don't get
the number 1 which you won't right you
see that whole list who's not on there
that I want us to take bold bold Oh
interest at the Tennessee problem okay
problem at the tip didn't porzingis have
some [ __ ] coming into now I don't know
about that I like ball ball no like
getting his ass kicked in Lithuania
others say there's another senators I
like and he's not even in that look at
the top ten player they don't have ball
ball listed if the Lakers stay where
they don't say whatever you want about
the one and done all I know is that the
beginning of the season
Nasr little was number two in this class
that does go second state so under that
other Center that's really good was at
Michigan State that was in like the
final four maybe yeah that's that guy
that guy's taco taco taco that's what
I'm talking about - I would take taco
taking bold bold no seriously though I'm
rebuilding the Lakers right here in the
last five minutes okay we draft
buh-buh-buh-buh and we sign Nikolai
Volkoff Mercker [ __ ] in Orlando okay
he's the East Coast joker okay Yogi's
guys call them from Texas again do you
got a rock are boner bro major do you
have a lighter sprawl does Texas love
American boners big I love it what's up
dude why you calling dude do you think
we called you [ __ ] talk about rock
our boners right now talk to us [ __ ]
about alright dude that's great great
Natalie was the :
don't take calls that's the call of
taking calls I'd prefer that call all
over us over this guy going over his
[ __ ] voicemail messages that to me is
absolutely hilarious
he thought weak basically dissolved
hello
we're like hello he goes hello right
yeah what are you doing why am i calling
I got no idea why Michael and Syme bulla
chick mercury [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
Nick Eliza's first name but no seriously
though he's from SC you know I'm saying
yeah seven footer average 21 and 12 last
year that's not bad yeah I mean he's the
East Coast joke of it like everyone
talks about LeBron Bobo volchok right I
mean it doesn't sound sexy blue and sexy
as [ __ ] where's your point guard
nobody's saying oh by the way you want
sexy looking bull balls face that is
sexy dad do you think that guy's gonna
come out looking sexy look
I will shock both balls dick by the way
don't you think just because you're ugly
I won't [ __ ] gargle your [ __ ] I got
a fast car you drive that's the kind of
face only a mother with no stare at 9:09
you're on would punch-drunk sportswear
winners win with rock-hard American
boners and thanks for calling have a
good day know what's going on Bobo
what's up Matt call for Sammartino want
are some Lakers okay let's talk what are
they doing with hiring that coach that
was going on no I wasn't with that move
either man like it's that it's the show
that we had no plan they sort of gave
tyloo two five-year deals I lose sucks
well you were just saying there's no
championship coaches out there he's one
of them that's true he's one of the few
female that was on the market that is
true and we know he works good with the
boys oh go ahead
and also why did they trace do box for
that made no sense
yeah Beasley cuz Beasley won the fight
loot walk well why couldn't we just
release Beasley like that what ended up
happening him anyway cuz what about you
muffled good players but all the Doc
Rivers of GM's I hung up on you because
you were yelling you just pissed off our
Mexican of the show Conan thanks for
tuning in thanks for tuning in
now but magic made some bad news man
Trading Zoo box yeah because they listen
rating Lou Williams Doc Rivers getting
LeBron because these guys don't want to
play basketball
they understand salary cap they it's
Chesbrough it doesn't matter how good do
the greatest GM's outside of Larry Bird
and Jerry West never played in the NBA
they don't know like dude the guy who
did Portland was a soap opera actor it's
not about being able to play it's about
playing chess dude knowing peace is the
move and understanding chemistry puzzle
together no I absolutely agree I'm not
fighting that at all everybody wants to
hire Chelsea Chauncey Billups who was a
great player is he cerebral up and I'm
nice and not say Oh Cruz's black adult
dude like you're lucky to be have one
great thing which is being athletic
enough to play in the NBA now you're
expecting them to be a [ __ ] unicorn
now expect them to know how to read
super sweet crazy
Yale and Harvard [ __ ] like you got
to be that kind of smart to make this
[ __ ] I just think that you have to have
a basketball acumen you have to know how
to put it's chemistry like you said it's
chess you know so it's more than it's
more to it than just oh this guy's good
oh I like this guy oh this guy's for my
favorite play I feel like that's what
Magic Johnson does more of you know I
mean dude who didn't get the entry the
the code what do you mean entry code
who's that guy talking Mariah Carey
didn't get the code what are you looking
for boner pills tell them blue to boner
pills punch-drunk well tell him give
them our punch-drunk boner pill [ __ ]
code
tell him it's [ __ ] punch-drunk boner
pills blue to boner pills blue to know
not sure what you want a mad lane why
don't you
why is Johnny not listening to what we
tell him to do
yeah well I don't understand what you're
saying just he's asking for a coke give
him our promo code no he's saying he
doesn't have the code given the promo
code for Boehner's type elephant dong
[Music]
hai you're the 9 to 5 you're calling in
to punch trunk I'm going on fella
what's up you like American boners bro
you're definitely getting that number
one pick Thanks easily they don't need
me they would lie on they do that desire
that would be stupid
why'd you put those two guys in now they
wouldn't do it cuz then what's trailer
but not and another reason I'm calling
what happened to do both man time to
call in they don't call in because
somebody had a baby and it doesn't want
to call it anymore that's not true on me
Oh [ __ ] show
I think the Diaz brothers in GSB don't
know the entry code and Sam when you
coming up really where I do we always
hang Crotched that's how you do it
that's how that was a good go that's
that's respect it's doing that's old so
that's a guy who's been listening
forever how are we not following Chris
Weidman
no block Chris Weidman we don't want him
on our [ __ ] shell oh you see that guy
fight me I know you're American one
thing you listen to Johnny
hurts my heart and my vagina Oh her
vagina is aching and that's a good now
we know how to get to Regina guys two
minutes we should block every single
person who follows us we don't do that
because they all sucked not even [ __ ] to
see them they would say one thing you
disagree with you be like block yeah but
then we made time follow you follow us
you're getting blocked
yeah single person calling the
punch-drunk right now Warren tell us who
we should block tell us who's we should
block we should block our sponsors no
don't do that don't do that we all do
that everyone else don't do that dude
Knicks are going to get the [ __ ] boom
bubble boiler oh dude super fan is dead
the Buffalo Bills the loss of super fan
Pancho Villa
what happened I'm glad he's dead do you
know who he is
who touched you one minute to show my
father okay let's go on it's going to
the [ __ ] X and this [ __ ] right
here I feel bad for Kareem cuz he
literally has to take a yoga class
another podcast you're already gonna
have a boner how quickly to this podcast
gets three [ __ ] specials on Comedy
Central what is it this is part of our
family you just joined it's called five
words and man they'll probably have
three Comedy Central they just like
really close like that you and me don't
pose like that for our pensions but
maybe we should I'm gonna say maybe
that's what Johnny what are you laughing
at you
[ __ ] you said they'll have specials in
two months
yeah but al magical give them both
specials in two months no no easy
they did a [ __ ] young comedians
special and they didn't put this guy
[ __ ] on why can't this guy because
I'm 50
well Eleanor's a spring chicken [ __ ]
rigging grooms a spring chicken
that's true why couldn't they put Jason
yeah thanks so what Jason [ __ ] a
reptile lady and [ __ ] and all I do is
kill Yeah right
he [ __ ] a lizard person in [ __ ]
Arizona I can't get a [ __ ]
special on Comedy Central gotcha gotcha
and on that note goodbye everybody this
has been punch on cream you killed as Oh
even though you went fully [ __ ] on
your [ __ ] MBA hey break down and I'm
really not kidding I definitely want to
be [ __ ] by a man ASAP
[Music]